lucie entre dans sa cuisine elle pousse
un cri son lave-vaisselle s'est brisé la
cuisine est inondée elle téléphone à son
assureur jeune expert en sinistre vient
évaluer les dégâts
quand lucie reçoit la réponse de
l'assureur l'hébreu lui en tombent
l'assureur acceptent de remplacer
seulement les armoires endommagé mais ce
type d'armoires n'existe plus
l'uci va donc se retrouver avec un
double look de cuisine cauchemardesque
pour elle l'assureur doit remplacer
toutes ses armoires mais elle se trompe
la loi oblige l'assureur a remplacé
seulement les biens endommagés par le
sinistre
l'uci devra donc se résigner à vivre
avec son double look ou payer de sa
poche de remplacement des armoires qui
ne sont pas endommagées le fin mot de
l'histoire assureurs ne rime pas avec
décorateur